the president actually asked the
Secretary of HHS and also the Attorney
General to initiate the administrative
process to review how marijuana is
scheduled the aircrafts want to
reschedule cannabis but that doesn't go
far enough moving cannabis to schedule 3
would allow for much needed research and
let existing businesses take advantage
of significant tax deductions however
rescheduling cannabis means it's still
federally illegal except for FDA
approved prescription-only products it
also wouldn't solve the industry's
banking problem keeping cannabis
federally illegal means banks are still
unwilling to provide services to State
licensed businesses schedule 3 drugs are
defined as those with moderate to low
potential for dependents like ketamine
anabolic steroids or Tylenol with
codeine cannabis doesn't belong in that
category
patients really want it in the drug war
deschedule cannabis entirely and granted
the same legal status as alcohol and
tobacco otherwise this is just a mids
move by Booth bureaucrats